[موسيقى]
4:30 صباحًا عندما يبدأ الفحص
qf 787-9 الرحلة من لندن إلى
سيدني تقلع قبل الفجر
ونتجه شرقًا وشروقنا الأول في
هذه الرحلة المزدوجة لشروق الشمس ،
إنه حدث طيران نادر لنفس
الرحلة إلى  شاهد شروق الشمس عبر
أيام مختلفة حتى أن الرئيس التنفيذي لشركة كانتاس يستغرق
وقتًا لالتقاط اللحظة التي تدور فيها هذه
الرحلة حول البحث لكل من الطاقم
والركاب الذين يتعلمون كيف
تختلف أوقات الجثث تمامًا مما يعني التمرين
لحسن الحظ أن الطائرة فارغة هذه الرحلة
هي مقاعد فارغة للمديرين التنفيذيين في شركة الطيران  يجب
أن يكونوا فارغين إذا كانوا ممتلئين
بالركاب الذين لن نصلهم إلى سيدني أبدًا ، فالرحلة
تتعلق أيضًا بالبحث مع
الطيارين وأنماط أدمغتهم
سوف تحتاج كانتاس إلى إقناع المنظمين
بالسماح للطيارين بالعمل لمدة تصل إلى
24 ساعة.  أنا أرتدي هذه الرؤية الأحادية
بمستوى الوعي الذي
تعمل به Mundek ، وسأنتقل إلى
واحدة مختلفة ليست وجبتنا الأولى
مصممة لتعزيز النوم ، لذا فإن الطريقة
التي صممنا بها صنعنا هي
الدعم المبكر  دورات النوم ودورات الاستيقاظ
طوال الرحلة ،
لدينا الخبز عالي المؤشر الجلايسيمي ونحمل
البروتين ونشجع على إنتاج
السيروتونين في منتصف الطريق هناك وفي الصين ،
البعض ينامون والبعض الآخر لا
أستمتع فقط بتجربة تجربتنا الثانية
يأتي شروق الشمس بينما نمر بالفلبين
، لقد اختبر Thor أقل من ألف
مسافر إجمالاً
هذا الشروق المضاعف الذي نطير فيه فوق
بحر الصين الجنوبي ، وقد
كنا نحلق جواً في أول 12 ساعة ولا
يزال لدينا ما
يعادل نيويورك للقيام بـ Qantas  لقد بذل الكثير
من المال والجهد في إجراء أبحاث طويلة المدى
أكثر بكثير من شركات الطيران الأخرى
التي لديها طرق مماثلة يشرح ألان جويس
سبب عدم قدرتك على القيام بهذا النوع من
الدراسة التي نقوم بها في
الرحلات الجوية المنتظمة التي سيتبعها الطيارون  مرتديًا
معدات الرأس ، سيختبرون
عينك ويمكنك القيام بذلك على
الرحلات الجوية المنتظمة التي يمكنك القيام بها في
رحلة التوصيل هذه قبل أن ننتقل بوقت طويل إلى
الاقتراب النهائي ، حيث أصبحت هذه الرحلات
أسرع بكثير مما توقعت.
لست متأكدًا تمامًا مما فعلته طوال
هذه الساعات التي هبطنا فيها في سيدني ، لذا
يبدو أننا قمنا بهذه
الرحلة الأطول في العالم في كل من الوقتين أكثر من
19000 دقيقة والمسافة التي تزيد عن
10000 ميل لتسجيل قتال واحد